if you've ever wondered how html works
well you've come to the right place in
this video today we'll be going through
some html basics and you're going to be
making your very first website using
html we'll be going over three things
today the first is what is html then
we'll be going through some basic syntax
and third you'll make a local website
that you can load in your browser one
thing to keep in mind is that we're not
gonna be going through any css or
javascript today so this website that
we're gonna be making is gonna be pretty
basic it's not gonna be all that pretty
sounds good let's get started
now what is html
html stands for hypertext markup
language it's a way of displaying
information on web pages in your browser
one thing to remember is that html isn't
itself a programming language it's a
markup language
programming languages like php or java
use things like logic and conditions to
control the content that you see
html doesn't do those things but it's
still extremely important
you can actually create an html file on
your computer and load it in your
browser it won't be on the internet so
only your local computer can view it
to create your html file open up your
computer's file program
in windows that's file explorer and on a
mac it's finder in the program go to
your desktop or wherever you want to put
the file
you'll want to create a new file in that
location
make sure that the file name reads
index.html
on windows if for some reason you can't
see the file extension just click on the
view tab and make sure that the file
name extensions checkbox is checked
when you have your file all set you'll
want to open it in the browser
if it has a chrome or other browser icon
on the left you can double click it to
automatically open it
if not you can also right click and
select open with and then select your
browser
now in the browser everything will look
blank which is fine because the file
doesn't have anything in it yet now in
addition to opening the file in your
browser you'll also want to open it in a
code editor
i'm using visual studio code and we're
going to keep both the editor and the
browser windows open next to each other
so it's easy to make code changes and
view them immediately in addition to
visual studio code there's a lot of
other programs that you can use you can
use notepad plus plus sublime atom or
brackets most of those are free and i've
included links to each of these in case
you want to download and install them
alright now that you have the index file
open in both your browser and your
editor we'll start writing some code
let's look at some of the basic features
of html
html is made up of tags
tags are special texts that you use to
markup or distinguish parts of your web
page hence the hypertext markup language
these tags tell the browser to display
whatever is inside the tag in a specific
way
so here's one example of a tag in action
i'm going to write out some text here
this is my very first website and i'm
extremely
excited exclamation points
and we'll save that
you can see that the words extremely
excited are in these b tags
b is for bold so let's save the file and
reload your browser and see what happens
all right you just wrote some html now
let's look at the tag again the tag
before the phrase is called the opening
tag
the tag after the phrase is called the
closing tag
you can also see that the closing tag
has a forward slash before the b
together these two tags tell the browser
to make whatever text is between them
bold and that's exactly what happened
now maybe this is obvious but when the
browser loads the html the tags
themselves are invisible they don't show
up on the page pretty cool huh
one reason i love making websites so
much is that it's almost like magic
being able to make things appear in the
browser window
everything good so far alright
now this line of text that we wrote is
working in the browser because we saved
the file as an html file
but for real html on the internet we
need to add some more tags to the file
in order for everything to work properly
so let's just make some space up here at
the top
and the very first tag that you need is
the doctype tag
talk type html
this isn't exactly an html tag but you
need it because it tells the browser
that this is an html5 document
this tag doesn't require a closing tag
because it's not surrounding any text
it's just declaring that this is html
if you're curious other doctypes that
were used in the past are html4 or xhtml
but right now html5 is really the only
doctype used so you won't have to worry
about those other kinds
then after the doctype tag you have the
main html tag this tag tells a browser
that everything inside it is html i know
it seems a bit redundant since you
already have used the html doctype tag
but this ensures that all the content
inside it will inherit some necessary
characteristics of html
then inside the main html tag your
content will usually be separated into
two sections
the head
and the body
the head tag contains information about
the website and it's also where you load
css and javascript files
we won't be looking at those today but
just so you know the body tag is the
main content in the web page everything
that you see on the page will usually be
in the body tag
so we need to move this sentence into
the body
there we go
now let's reload the page
make sure you save first and it should
look exactly the same so we're all good
here now let's go into some of the basic
tags that are commonly used in the head
and the body
i'm not going to go through every single
possible tag in existence so we'll just
be looking at the ones that are used
most often so that you can get a better
idea of how an html page is put together
now the first tag that should be in your
head is this meta tag
meta and then you're setting the care
set to be
utf-8
utf-8 is a type of unicode encoding used
in virtually all websites around the
world
we need encoding because we need to
translate the letters numbers and
symbols that we use into bytes used by
computers
you can think of it as a sort of
dictionary translating human languages
into computer speak now the next meta
tag that should be on all websites
is this viewport tag
so you set the name attribute to
viewport
then you have a content attribute
and you set it to width equals device
width
initial
scale
1.
this may be a little
you know confusing or computer
gobbledygook looking but this is
important for responsive websites
responsive means that the website can
display properly on all devices
computers tablets and mobile phones the
content in this tag is saying that it
should make the width of the website the
same width as whatever device that is
viewing it
for example a mobile phone has a much
smaller screen resolution or size as a
laptop computer
this will let the website resize itself
according to what the user is using
then the initial scale sets the zoom of
the website
on browsers nowadays you can zoom in and
out making the website look bigger or
smaller
we want it to be set at one by default
meaning not zoomed in or out
now after these two meta tags
one of the most important tags that
we're going to use is the title tag
as you can probably guess this sets the
title of the web page
if a website has different pages each
page can have its own title
so we'll add the title here
my first website
we'll save the file and then we'll
reload
and you can see up here at the top in
the browser tab it has the title my
first website
so that's it for the head tags now let's
go into the body
we'll just keep the previous html that
we wrote up here so it'll still stay on
the website
most of the basic body tags are based on
things you could do in word documents
you can create headlines bold text make
lists and even tables
in the days before css using these tags
helped to organize and stylize your
content so that it would be more easily
understood by your reader
not all these tags that we're going to
go into are still used as much as they
used to be
some of them simply aren't needed
anymore because we can now use css to
achieve the same style
but i think it's still helpful to at
least know what these basic tags are
let's look first at the headline or
header tags designated with the letter h
each h tag also has a number after the h
and they range from h1 to h6
the h1 tag is the highest in priority
it's generally used for the title of the
page
we're going to add an h1 tag to our web
page
inside the tag we'll put the title of
the webpage
my first
website
save and reload
and you can see here's the title
let's now also add a subtitle using the
h2 tag
and we'll put in an html playground
you can see that the subtitle is
displayed at a smaller font size than
the title
now just for fun we'll put in all the h
tags up through h6 just so you can see
what it looks like
so h3
h4
h5
and h6
now this is a little bit much most
websites don't use all the h tags
usually they'll just use h1 for the
title h2 for the subtitle and h3
sometimes for section titles it's pretty
rare these days to use h4 h5 and h6 tags
now the next tag we're going to look at
is the paragraph or the p tag
just like in word you can use paragraphs
to separate your content into blocks
you can create your paragraph by
surrounding your content with the p tags
we're going to make a paragraph with
some placeholder text
one of the easiest ways to find
placeholder text is to google for lorem
ipsum
lorem ipsum text is nonsense latin words
that are used in publishing and design
to fill in text in order to work on the
layout
so we'll copy this paragraph here
and we'll put it into a p tag
now let's make a second paragraph too
we'll copy some more text
and put it into
another p tag
now let's see what this looks like
so there we have it the browser
automatically adds some space between
the paragraphs and other content
now if you want to separate your content
onto multiple lines but you don't want
that space that comes with a paragraph
you can use a line break or a br tag
so let's get some more lorem ipsum text
and put it into our editor without a p
tag this time
now one interesting thing to note about
html is that
it won't automatically break lines
so if you press enter a bunch of times
in the text
you're not going to see anything
different on the page and the same goes
for if you press spacebar a whole bunch
of times
it looks exactly the same
what html does is that it will only
allow one space between a bunch of
enters or spaces
in order to create an actual line break
you need to add the br tag
so let's try that here let's get rid of
this extra space since it's not doing
anything
and we'll add in abr tag
so now you can see
that this sentence is starting on the
next line
you can even add multiple br tags
and doing so will add space between your
content
you'll notice that on the br tags they
don't have a closing tag
it doesn't need one because it's not
used to surround text kind of like that
doctype tag at the top
these types of tags that don't need a
closing tag are called void elements
void meaning empty because they have no
content
one other thing to note about this is
that you might sometimes see the line
break written as br with the closing
slash
this was a requirement for xhtml but in
html5 we don't need this slash
the browser will still read the tag
correctly but i'd still recommend
writing these void elements without that
slash
the next set of tags we're going to look
at are style tags these tags add styles
to the text they can be bold like we did
in the very beginning and there's also
italics underline emphasized and strong
tags
like we said before these style tags
aren't used as much anymore because now
you can use css to style everything it's
pretty straightforward what they do and
we'll go through each of them here
now let's use the b tag again
and we'll make this line of text
bold
and we can see it's bold
now let's do the italics or the i tag
next
i'm just going to put this on a new line
add the i tag
and we'll load the page and you can see
it's now italics
we'll just keep doing the same thing for
all the rest of these tags
so the next one we'll look at is the
underline or the u tag
and it's underlined
then we'll do the emphasize or em tag
you'll notice that the default for
emphasize is just italics again
and the same thing goes for the strong
tag
the strong tag is basically the same
thing as the bold tag
so that's it for the style tags
now let's look at the horizontal rule
this will create a line on your web page
we'll just add this in here
and hr is the horizontal rule tag
so let's reload that you'll see you now
have a horizontal line going across the
entire web page
you can see that the content before the
hr tag is above the line and the content
after the hr tag is below the line
now the link tag
as you probably know links are one of
the main ways that we get around the
internet right you go to one website to
look at stuff then you click a link to
go to another website and so on
so let's make a link tag here
the link tag is written as an a tag
now that a stands for anchor because the
link connects the two websites like a
boat anchor connects the boat to
whatever it's anchoring to
first put the a tag around the link text
that you want to be clickable as we've
done here
now in addition to just writing the tag
you need to add an attribute
the main attribute that you need to add
on your a tag is href this stands for
hypertext reference
and inside this attribute you want to
put in the url of the website that you
want this link to go to so let's say we
want to link to the google home page
so we'll add an href
value of https
www.google.com
now let's reload the page
you can see here that this text is the
purple color
purple means that you've actually
visited that link before and if the link
is the link that you've never been to
before it'll be blue text
now if we click that
lo and behold it loads the google home
page
let's go back to our website
url stands for universal resource
locator
this acts as an address that will give
you the location of the webpage or the
file that you want to load
now another often used attribute in the
a tag is target
this controls if the link that you click
will open in the same page that you are
on or if it will open a new page or new
tab in your browser
if you don't have a target attribute
by default the browser will load the
link in the same page
let's add a target
and we want to load
in a new web page so we'll type in
underscore blank
we'll save that reload it and then now
click on the link again
and you'll see that the google homepage
has loaded in a new tab
the next thing we'll look at is images
to put an image on your web page you can
use the image tag written out as img
so let's add that to our website
now it's blank so it's not going to
display anything on our website if we
reload it
similar to the link tag we just did the
image tag needs a url but instead of
href like the links use the image tag
has an attribute of src meaning the
source of the image
so we'll add in that attribute
now in order to put an image on here we
need to find an image let's say on the
internet to use for this example one
really helpful place that i go to for
test images is placeholder.com
so let's go there
this website is super helpful because
you can generate an image of any size
depending on the values that you put in
the url
so
let's just copy this
and then we'll add it into our source
now let's see how that looks
you can see the images there
i'm just going to add a quick
br tag here to separate the image from
the content
now like we said on the website you can
actually
put in different values to get different
sizes
of images so let's try this let's make
it 600 pixels by 300 pixels 300
and now the image is bigger
another thing you can do is instead of
loading an image from the internet which
by the way this isn't really a suggested
practice
the better thing to do is to just
download that image to your computer or
wherever you're going to save it
so we'll save this image here
and now if we open up our file explorer
again you can see that in addition to
the index.html file we now have this png
file
pngs are simply a type of image file
that you can use
so now if we want to refer to this image
that we have on our computer
instead of this url we'll simply put in
the file name
600x300.png
and we'll see now that this will load
now there's another attribute that you
can add to your image tag and that's the
border attribute adding this in will as
you might imagine add a border around
your image so let's give this a shot
we've added a border attribute and put
in 10 as the value
we'll reload our page and now you see
that the image has a 10 pixel wide
border around it again this is one of
the attributes that you don't really
need to use anymore because you can do
this all in css but it's helpful for you
to know that it exists
now the next thing we're going to look
at is lists
html can create bulleted or numbered
lists pretty easily
bulleted lists are called unordered
lists as opposed to the ordered lists
that use numbers
now to create a list you'll use the list
tag either ol or ul depending on if
you're making an ordered or unordered
list
we're going to make an unordered
bulleted list of different types of
fruits so we'll first put in our
ul tag
for the list and inside this list tag
you'll put your list items
each item will go inside its own list
item tag written as li
so we'll add in
apples
oranges
uh pineapples
mangoes
and dragon fruit just to make it
interesting
now if we load our page
we'll see that we now have a bulleted
list of all the fruits that we put in
here
now just for you to see if we change
this unorder list to an ordered list
you can see that the bullets are now
replaced by numbers
but we just want to work with the
unordered list right now
another thing that you can do is you can
even nest lists inside one another
so let's say i want to add different
types of apples under apples we would
create a new list tag inside the list
item in question with its own list items
so within the apple li tag we'll
actually add a new ul tag
under the apple text
then we'll add li tags each with a
different type of apple so let's put in
golden delicious
granny smith
and gala
we'll reload our page and you can see
now under apples we have another child
list indented even more than the
original list was
this brings me to an important aspect of
writing good html
if you put an html tag inside another
one that's called nesting not so much
bird type nesting but more like a
russian doll nesting an element inside
another one is called a child element
and the outer element is called the
parent
so in this case the apples list item is
the parent item of the apple type list
in order to organize the parent and
child elements we indent the child
element this helps it distinguish from
the parent
so you can see with this list of fruits
i've indented the main list items apples
oranges pineapples and so on from the ul
tag
then inside the apples list item i've
indented once more to create the
unordered list tag indented yet again to
put in the list items for the types of
apples
doing things like this helps keep your
code clean
it doesn't matter to the computer but
for humans reading your code it will
enable you and other people to quickly
understand what your code is all about
if all the html elements weren't
indented at all and were all on the same
level things would look a lot more
confusing let's just demonstrate this
with the list
so i've now unindented everything
and you can see that it's a little
harder to see that there is an apples
child list using the types of apples
so it's just better to keep all your
code indented nicely
in this practice of indenting it's
considered good practice not just for
html but also for css javascript and
basically any programming language
that's in existence
at my first job indenting was the first
thing that i was taught during my
training it's pretty important because
there's nothing worse than having to
work on someone else's code and having
it be a complete mess so indenting is an
easy way to make sure that you're
writing code that other people and
yourself in the future can go back and
read and speaking of indenting and
nesting elements the last html tag that
we're going to go through uses a lot of
that it's the table
tables were originally used as an
efficient way to organize data into rows
and columns
kind of like an excel spreadsheet if you
worked with those before
so to demonstrate the table let's make a
table for a hypothetical monthly budget
of a household
now to start we'll first need the table
tag
everything else inside the table will be
inside this table tag
we'll have rows
table cells and table headers for the
column headers
so let's add in our first row
and this row is going to be the one
containing the column headers
so inside the table row tag we'll add in
a th or table header tag
and we'll write in our column headers
now so we'll start with the month
then we'll add in some budget categories
so we'll do rent
utilities
groceries
because you gotta eat
and then eating out
and then we'll do entertainment because
you know you want to have some fun stuff
to do
now let's load that and see how it looks
now you'll see here that we have all the
different column headers listed out next
to one another
for the next row we'll add in some data
for the month of august
so make another tr tag for this second
row
and
the data that we're going to put in
these table cells aren't headers so
we'll just use the td or table data or
table cell tag so inside this td tag
we'll put in some numbers for each of
these different categories first one
we'll put in august because
august is under the month column header
then for the next one it's rent so let's
say
our rent is 1500 per month
after rent we'll have utilities and
let's just say 150 for utilities
then
350 for groceries
a hundred dollars for eating out
and then for entertainment let's just do
50 bucks
all right let's reload and see how that
looks
you can see here that we've created the
second row and everything's aligned
together under the proper column header
so this table you know looks like it's
working but it's kind of basic looking
right
well we can style this table a little
bit with some of the built-in table
attributes
the first thing we want to do is add
lines to the table because it's kind of
hard to see what's out here
so in the table tag
you can add a border attribute
and then we'll put in one this will add
a border that's one pixel
there we go now if we want to we can
make this number bigger so let's say we
want a border of 10.
and here's the table and you'll notice
that the
the border that's 10 pixels wide is just
the main border outside the entire table
and the borders inside the table are
still set to one pixel this is just the
default way that tables are displayed in
the browser the other thing you can do
is
cell padding and cell spacing
so cell padding
controls the amount of extra space
inside each cell
from the text to the border so let's try
a cell padding of 10.
there we go there's a little more
breathing room now inside our table
the other thing you can do is
sell spacing
and let's just
do this at 10 to see what it looks like
and now you can see that between each
cell is 10 pixels
i don't want to have any space between
the cells so i'm going to actually
change this to zero
and there we have it nice neat looking
table
when you're building an html table one
thing that you really need to make sure
of is to have the same number of columns
in each row in the table
otherwise things will get kind of messed
up so let me show you what this looks
like if i delete the groceries cell
delete this
resave and then load
so you can kind of see how the headers
have now kind of shifted over and
there's this weird blank space at the
end because there's no table cell there
so
let's just put that back
however one thing you can do is you can
make one table cell span multiple
columns
so let's say we wanted to break out the
utilities category to have two types of
data one for your water and one for your
electricity
we'll say that electricity is 100 and
the water is 50
so in total it's still 150.
to do this we'll actually create an
extra cell in the data and adjust the
amounts of the utilities
so we'll duplicate the utility cell then
we'll change the first amount to the
electricity at a hundred dollars and the
second one to be fifty dollars for the
water
now just for your own interest if we
reload again we'll see that table looks
weird because
we have these two cells that we have
added so there's one more cell in the
second row than there is in the first
row now to make both these hundred and
fifty dollar cells be under the
utilities cell
we'll use an attribute called call span
or column span
so under the utilities table header
we'll say
call span equals two
this will make the table header
utilities span two columns so now you
can see that everything looks nice and
neat together again because the
utilities table cell is spanning both
columns the hundred and the fifty dollar
column
looks pretty organized doesn't it
so in addition to call span you can also
use the row span attribute to make a
cell span multiple rows
let's say we had data for june july and
august and we wanted to designate all
those months as fall
so i'm just going to copy and paste
again and use the august data to create
june and july data 2.
so i'll copy this row
paste it a couple times
then we'll just rename
this one to june
and the next one to july
so now we see that we have three rows
june july and august
so to create the cell for fall
i want it to be to the left of the
months
so starting with june
i'll go to the june row and i will
create a new table cell before june
and put
fall
in it
now again we'll see if i just load this
little the data is kind of messed up
so i'll go back to the fall table cell
and then i'll add the
row span attribute
and make it span three rows because we
want fall to be in front of june july
and august
so let's save that
and there we go
now you can see that this also still
looks a bit incorrect because there's an
extra blank space here at the end on the
header row and fall
isn't under month we want the month to
be on top of june july and august
so what we'll do is we'll add an extra
table cell on the top header
so now
if we reload we can see that everything
has the proper number of cells
now aside from using tables to contain
data tables actually used to be used by
web developers to layout web designs
so for example if you have a website
designed with a header main content and
a footer you could create you know one
big table with three rows and then you
can put all your content in those table
cells
because the table cells can contain any
kind of html you know images links text
you name it it was pretty handy back in
the day
nowadays tables aren't really used very
often the only common exception that i
can think of is for html emails this is
because some older email systems can't
really use a lot of css so coding like
it's 1999 is unfortunately the only
option
so that's it about tables
and there you have it you made your very
first website using basic html
if you want to download the site files
as well as a cheat sheet that i've made
of the html tags we went through today
please click the link down below also if
you enjoyed this video and want to keep
following hit that subscribe button and
the like button and that's it for today
see you later
[Music]